heurtaux l'attendait ce constat tout à
l'heure voilà donc vous avez compris il
me manque quelques battre est-ce qu en
fait cyril est toujours un peu dans la
dans la provocation et futurs des petits
mouvements l'âge est là et là là là
maintenant c'est fini je vais appeler un
pro de la castagne c'est gras gay moment
où des abus voilà mon jour de la guerre
ça très bien alors greg il est costaud
voilà ça c'est bien voilà c'est dit
droit oui quand même temps oui mais je
travaille je travaille bon greg voilà
j'ai un problème cyril passe son temps
un peu un provoquer et écolo c'est comme
sur la séquence qu'aimes tu dois quand
même toit plus de cinq hommes seraient
donc attention attention donc qu'est-ce
que je peux faire par exemple imaginons
imaginons je suis là tranquillement les
jeux la syrie et vente veut m'arracher
mes fiches comment je peux comment je
peux parler de maths affiche
voilà qui me l'arraché non non ce que
nathan sur wii bon déjà c'est un jeu de
gamins qui es tu le retires à c'est tout
mais c'est surtout c'était bien la peine
de faire appel à bord de deux castes
akbar conseille aussi mais ça c'est pour
vous ce qui était faux mais oui ça déjà
comme ça et et des petits frères à 3 to
me sujets seront sur scène a reculé
durant c'est ça merci beaucoup
alors c'est tout mais qu'est ce que je
dis et imaginons alors imaginons ses
effets souvent ce mouvement-là ici voilà
je ne me casse pas toujours tu l'ouvrés
vers l'extérieur c'est à dire par là bas
ici à thé voir comme ça à plat fait
comme ça est ce que tu fais frérot
proteam tourner les fesses comme ça mais
je fasse quoi quand je t'envoie le coup
de pied va dire on va le coupé voilà bah
voilà presqu'un jean claude van damme ya
beaucoup de tweets y en ait beaucoup de
jeunes de la personne qui voudrait voir
un petit peu ce qu'elle solti succès
c'est pas le taux de femmes mariole les
loups alors bien bien dans nos poches
alors ça c'est important parce que cyril
il passe son temps à vouloir me promener
sur ma page
imaginons hop je suis là alors entonné
en 2000 billets
hu
samir est anodine billets alors là moi
non j'ai dit au micro je peux pas
franchement assez assez impressionnant
race et nos recettes du cul des plages
mais away en fait en fait vous kiffez en
fait ah mais oui c'est les sportifs
sévère je peux te pousser un peu pour
voir un haut et non pas moi je suis en
train de travailler ses yeux jeudi bec
ses yeux voilà mal à baisser les
imaginant regarde je veux prendre ses
billets alors qu'ils m'attrapent et le
bim attention attention et bien alawiya
voilà attention parce que j'ai appris
beaucoup
ah oui alors c'est bon alors tiens
prends 3.0 c'est pas moi patron je sais
par contre c'est vraiment de la merde ce
décor bon les amis on vous l'a dit c'est
bon on est et commence à casser le décor
me faire engueuler chérie je suis désolé
c'est lui un cessez de ce pom a forcé et
une balance la lune avait carrément
c'est l'heure de vérité nous sommes
devant la loge de cyanide et de là et là
et aux samoa le mariole parce que là il
ya greg mêmes akela à hello hello petit
cyril est là et qui sait qu'elle a aimé
voir celle des patois je suis pas du
tout content
[Musique]
il est tombé si bas qu'elle arrête
hier soir on sur couverture de charlie
hebdo
évidemment ça fait polémique on va dans
les notes
[Rires]